أولاً ، أريد أن
أسألك شيئًا عنك قلته لـ npr اليوم ،
قلت إنه إذا حصل غالبية الأمريكيين على
سعر التطعيم ، فيمكننا أن نبدأ
حقًا في الحصول على بعض السيطرة الجيدة على هذا الأمر
حيث نعود إلى خريف عام 2022
بعد عام من الآن  هل هذا هو أفضل
سيناريو وما الذي يبدو عليه عنصر التحكم
لا ، أنت تعرف ،
أنت تعرف
أندرسون ، يجب أن أعتذر عندما
أستمع إلى الشريط الذي قصدت قوله في
ربيع عام 2022 ، لذا لم أخطئ
في الحديث وفي المحادثة مع ماري لويز
كيلي كانت تقول متى أعتقد
أننا سنبدأ في الحصول على بعض السيطرة ،
قلت إذا كان بإمكاننا
تجاوز هذا الشتاء والحصول حقًا على
الغالبية العظمى من 90 مليون
شخص لم يتم تطعيمهم ،
آمل أن نتمكن من البدء  للحصول على
بعض السيطرة الجيدة في ربيع عام
2022. لم أقصد الخريف ، لقد أخطأت في التعبير عن حسن حظي السيئ ،
ما الذي يتحكم في ما
الذي يعنيه ذلك وما الذي
يبدو لك
جيدًا بالنسبة لي هذا يعني أنه لديك
إما  الغمر  إن الغالبية العظمى من
السكان الذين تم تطعيمهم
سيكون لديهم درجة من
الحماية وتخلصوا من الفيروس وننصح أن
يتم تطعيم هؤلاء الأشخاص أيضًا
بسبب درجة الحماية
التي يمكن أن تحفزها
في شخص مصاب
بعد ذلك تعافى ثم تم تطعيمه يعد
زيادة هائلة في درجة
الحماية إذا تمكنا من القيام بذلك مع
الأشخاص المصابين ،
أعاد تطعيم الأشخاص
غير المحصنين الآن بعد أن تم تطعيم 90 مليون
شخص لهم أعتقد أننا نستطيع  الحصول على
درجة من الحماية
الشاملة للمجتمع والتي عندما نصل إلى
الجزء الأول من عام 2022 نمر خلال
فصل الشتاء والذي قد يكون معقدًا بسبب
الإنفلونزا بسبب فيروس الجهاز التنفسي المخلوي
الذي يمكن
أن نبدأ في العودة إلى درجة
الحالة الطبيعية ، أي إعادة طرح الأشياء
التي كنا نأمل أن نتمكن من القيام بها في
مسارح المطاعم من هذا النوع ،
ولكن مرة أخرى ، هناك مشكلة كبيرة  aveat هناك
أندرسون ، هذا فيروس متوحش للغاية
اعتقدنا أننا سنحصل على هذه
الدرجة من الحرية حيث وصلنا إلى الرابع
من يوليو والصيف ، ثم
تأتي لكمة كرة القدم مع
متغير دلتا وهو أمر غير عادي في
قدرته  بالانتشار من
شخص لآخر ، لذلك نأمل أن نكون هناك في
الإطار الزمني الذي ذكرت
أنه ربيع عام 2022 بشكل صحيح ولكن
لا يوجد ضمان لأن الأمر متروك
لنا
إذا واصلنا البقاء دون
تطعيم هؤلاء الأشخاص ، فيجب
تطعيمهم هذا.  يمكن أن يستمر
الأمر في تطوير
متغير آخر يمكن أن يعقد الأمور ، لذا
فمن الممكن أن نسيطر على هذا الأمر
، وما هو الشخص الذي سيتم
تطعيمه ، ما هي النسبة المئوية من
السكان الذين سيحتاجون إلى
التطعيم حتى لو كانوا قد حصلوا عليه  قبل أن
نحتاج إلى التطعيم من أجل الحصول على
هذا النوع من التحكم بشكل
صحيح
أندرسون بكل شفافية وصدق
لا نعرف ذلك لأننا لم
نقم  النقطة التي وصلنا إليها
هناك
ثم سقطت أدناه ثم شاهد الفيروس
يعود